- Here is your chance to ask Blake, John,
Gwen, Carson and me what
you've always wanted to know
about the show.
Let's keep it family, it's a daytime show,
(audience laughs)
Let's start with Brie, where's Brie?
Hey Brie!
- Hi guys, so first of all,
I'm obsessed with all of you,
You guys are like my favorite,
my first question's for Carson.
So sometimes they kinda like take a while
to decide what they're gonna
say to the contestants,
so my questions was, which
one annoys you the most?
(audience laughs)
- What?
- Wait, like which one of us
takes the longest?
- Annoys me?
- Yeah, like while, during that yeah.
- Kelly takes the longest, yeah.
(audience laughs)
And I know this because she just starts,
well she has the gift
of gab as you all know.
(audience laughs)
So she just starts talking really fast.
- He takes long too!
- And then she starts sweating profusely.
(audience laughs)
You're a sweater.
- No, I do sweat, I get so
sweaty 'cause I'm nervous!
'cause I don't want them to home.
He, you take long too,
- I don't even have
You just take forever
to finish your sentence.
- I don't even have really a thought.
So how can I, how can I,
- Whatever!
- How can I take a long
time to say anything?
- Whatever!
- The hardest part we deal with--
- [Brie] I do have a second
question for you guys.
- Sorry.
- Okay, okay.
- Um, so girls especially,
so I know we can't really
see your feet while you guys
are like taping the show,
so do you guys like wear your shoes
'cause I know I wouldn't,
'cause I hate shoes.
- Um, I'm with you Brie, and
now that I know you don't see
my shoes, I will now be barefoot.
(audience laughs)
- I'm down, we'll be barefoot together.
- I am so uncomfortable!
That's good to know that nobody's sees it.
- And I'm actually super
upset because I love my shoes
and I feel like they were
being shown the whole time.
(audience laughs)
So, that sucks.
- See? We are so different.
- I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
- Waste of thousands of
dollars you've wasted.
(audience cheers)
- What these old things?
- Exactly! All right!
- Hundreds of thousands of dollars wasted.
- Exactly. Next, Davion where you at?
Hey Davion!
(applause)
- How you guys doin' how you guys doin'.
- [Kelly] Where are you from?
- Oh, I'm from Riverside, California.
- Oh right on! What's your question?
- If you guys had to
audition for the voice,
what would you sing?
(audience oohs)
- Good question.
- Well, I think about the
songs I cover in my show
like I do "A Bridge Over
Troubled Waters" sometime.
I do a really interesting
version of "Dancing in the Dark"
the Bruce Springsteen song.
So maybe, some of those songs
that I cover in my shows
are the songs I would do on The Voice too.
- Solid, solid.
- He could sing anything, he
could sing a nursery rhyme
and chairs would turn.
(audience laughs)
- What would yours be Gwen?
- That's, I was, my
mind actually went blank
I was like, trying to go through my brain,
I'm like I know that this
show would not be for me.
Like I am from a garage.
- [Kelly] What?
Like I'm from. I'm
saying, I am from a band
that was in a garage
that worked my way up.
Like I can't imagine,
I'm not, I can't imagine.
- You know what's so funny,
on the song we just sang
though "Neon Moon" I'm not kidding,
I've been telling everyone backstage,
we love country music
and grew up on that song,
but you were my favorite voice on it.
- Oh my god! I love you!
- [Kelly] Because--
- No, because it, no it is!
(applause)
Because, because your voice.
- No, because I'm always, I honestly,
- No where is it?
- Everybody here,
I always feel like, I'm between them,
like he's actually, the best
singer I've ever witness sing.
- Whoa!
- In my entire life.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- He's powerful.
- [Gwen] No.
(audience cheers)
But I always feel like I have
to like, keep up with you guys
'cause I mean you're, its just a whole.
- I know but we turn a lot for
tone, and I think your tone
- You would turn for me?
- I grew up on your music!
(audience laughs)
Yes! I was like I literally
have loved you since
"Trapped in a Box" that is
way more than anyone here.
(audience cheers)
Like I, like I love your tone.
But, well what song would you choose?
- "Lick It Up" by Kiss.
(audience laughs)
- [Carson] Oh, please
- Perfect, perfect.
- You're so stupid. My okay, I--
(laughs)
You're dumb. Mine would,
- You're just waiting
to say that by the way
(Gwen laughs)
- Mine would be either an Aretha song,
well I mean that's kid of a dumb question
I've actually done this on TV.
- [John] It's like what would I do
if I were in a competition?
- You know what, if I
were in a vocal compiti-
no I really did wanna
sing "Why" by Annie Lennox
and no one would, um,
let us sing their songs
on the first season of
Idol, so I didn't get to.
But I would sing "Why" by Annie Lennox.
Its one of my favorite songs.
- Nice, nice.
- [Gwen] Wow I love that song.
- Um thanks so much Davion!
(applause)